I'm joy and I do the afternoon show at
way FM radio that a Steven Curtis
Chapman on way of M or Carlos enjoy well
just joy today
Carlos is gone and I heard about Dave
Ramsey right after college because I was
in a whole bunch of debt I went to one
of those private Christian colleges and
I was dead set on going even though I
couldn't pay for it so I came out with a
whole lot of loans to pay off
and unfortunately Christian radio
doesn't pay tons of money so I decided
that I wanted my life to look different
and as I started asking people questions
like how do we how do you budget how do
you make it when your income isn't quite
enough what do you do and all of my
friends pointed me towards Financial
Peace University and one of my first
co-workers at yfm it had an amazing
experience with Financial Peace
University so he said you got to get in
this class I found one at my church and
as I started working through it I was
learning the basic skills of how to
handle finances for the very first time
it was new it was difficult learning
about it really helped me to get into a
place where now I can't believe three
years later that I'm gonna be debt-free
that I get to do this debt-free scream
right after I took Financial Peace
University for the very first time I
knew I had to get out of debt but I
didn't know what to do because my salary
was barely giving me enough just to
survive on so I saw a second job
opportunity come my way I mean I do a
radio show for my normal job but I found
another job where I could voice track
another radio show and I did it in the
evening so I've been doing that job for
three years and while it's still a great
job it's been really difficult like
doing that job for three straight years
I worked holidays I work every single
day and there's been moments in the
middle that I thought I just want to
quit I just want to do this anymore and
it's been hard to prioritize my life
that income from the second job has
completely gone towards my debt so
you're here to do your debt-free screams
yes I'm so excited I love it well
welcome alright so how much debt to be
paid off joy I paid off thirty five
thousand dollars I love it way to go and
how long did that take it took me three
years it was it was a long long time but
it was wonderful okay well we're honored
that we were able to participate a
little bit with a fellow radio
personality here 11 turn you were able
to see you turn this around and I'm glad
we were a tiny part of that you're there
you're the hero I'm proud of you alright
joy from Nashville
$35,000 paid off in three years making
fifty thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
well done well done well done